un mot de commentaires sur ses sursis
tweet il ne vous surprennent pas mais
quand même même si on s'y attendait nous
autres journalistes a fait tout à fait
quand même des mois qu'on s'est dit ça
va être énorme mais on est quand même
surpris non oui bah on est surpris oui
mais on s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait si
vous voulez encore une fois il croit
qu'il n'ya pas une autre personnalité
qui peut dégager un pareil
pari tendresse finalement parce que
c'est une tendresse que la france dégage
aujourd'hui 1 c'est exactement ça c'est
on aime beaucoup un peu mais il c'est
quelqu'un qui nous attendrit c'est comme
c'était pas de l'adie ses origines son
comportement qui a toujours été quand
même même si c'était un type de boîte de
nuit d'ailleurs est ce intéressant quand
il dit il raconte ses bois de 8,6 il a
peur de la nuit dans le lit cariou qu'il
accorde à daniel rondeau chez nos
confrères du monde à la fin des années
90 il dit j'avais peur de la nuit j'ai
peur de la nuit ici j'ai peur de la nuit
bah pour pas pour pour surmonter ses
peurs je vais en boîte de nuit parce
qu'évidemment il y avait les moyens et
puis quand il aller en boîte de nuit il
emmenait tous ses copains jean reno tout
le monde y allait il servait tout le
monde il dit je détestais la musique qui
passait parce que pour moi c'était elle
était inaudible je déteste danser je
déteste danser mais j'étais là pour tuer
le temps finalement pour surmonter cette
angoisse que j'avais de la nuit bon il
ya une tendresse pour ce pour cet homme
qui comme vous l'avait bien dit aussi a
su rebondir à chaque fois finalement
aussi bien dans sa vie privée parce que
ça apparaît rien mais deux avec laeticia
ça fait 20 ans qu'il était marié qui est
ici avait eu deux enfants dans
lesquelles
il a adopté deux enfants avec elle il a
il a su passer les modes il a donc il ya
quelque chose et il n'aura semble
finalement moi je passe mal